while some breaking news coming out of
the United Kingdom where judges have
blocked government plans to deport
Asylum Seekers to Rwanda the court of
appeal in London ruled that the plans
were unlawful rights groups and Asylum
Seekers appealed an earlier decision by
another Court which gave the go-ahead
for the controversial deportation policy
Nadine barber joins us now live from
London so Nadine Clarity from uh the
courts we now wait to hear what the
government response will be
that's right so hail Clarity on some of
the argument put forward by lawyers
representing Asylum Seekers who had been
told they were at risk of being sent to
Rwanda to Lodge an asylum claim there as
in that they would never be allowed to
put in a claim in Britain now the um the
uh decision last year the ruling that
Rwanda was a safe country has now been
overturned by a majority ruling by three
judges here for a bit more on this I'm
joined by the director of Asylum Aid one
of the groups involved Alison pickup
Alison Obviously good news where does
this leave your your clients the people
that you represent yeah absolutely
delighted by this news today that the
height that the court of appeal has
overturned the high court as you said
and found it's not safe for Asylum
Seekers to be sent to Rwanda and with
for our clients this is really important
because they were under throat got many
clients under threat of being sent to
Rwanda very scared of being sent there
and they will be hugely reassured that
the court has said they can't be sent
there all along the British government
has argued that Rwanda has put in
safeguards but it is a suitable place
for people to Lodge a claim and if
they're successful stay there and even
if not they're saying that there are
Provisions Protections in place what do
you say to that so the court of appeal
has accepted today that the evidence
just doesn't support
now the U.N Refugee agency intervened in
the appeal putting forward their
experience of veranda's Asylum system
and the court has accepted that it's
just not safe at the moment and that
there's a real danger that Zion Seekers
would be sent back to countries where
they're at risk of persecution the very
places they've fed from in the first
place now of course the rwanda's schemes
was was signed uh last spring so it's
been more than a year now for some
people who are here in Britain some of
them in detention not knowing what's
going to happen tell me a bit about what
effect that's having on Asylum Seekers
yeah so it's really hard for the Asylum
Seekers because they're just left in a
limbo some of them have experienced
torture they've been traffic they've
been exploited on their way to the UK
they've had very traumatic Journeys by
definition and now they've been left
waiting for over a year to find out if
they will be allowed to even make their
case in this country or they'll be
Central Rwanda a country they know
nothing about so I think this hopefully
coming to an end uh will give them that
reassurance of safety now the government
here is all already pushing ahead with
an illegal immigra illegal migration
bill which has caused a lot of
consternation particularly around the
prospect of children being put into
detention and then deported does do you
think this ruling has any bearing on the
government how the government goes
forward yeah absolutely the the plan and
the illegal migration bill which is
effectively a refugee ban is to prevent
anyone from claiming Asylum and the
government then wants to detain them men
women children families people who've
been trafficked people who've been
tortured and send them off to another
country well the high court has now said
they can't send them to Rwanda because
it's not safe and they need to make sure
that they're going to need to reconsider
that policy thank you very much for your
time well uh just a reminder that the UK
government still has the option of
appealing this to a higher court it's
already been a long legal process but as
we are reminded all of the delay is
having an effect on some of the most
vulnerable people who try to reach
Britain thanks very much Nadine barber
there for us in London